good morning John I have happily
upgraded my filming situation in
airports to a little booth that I pay
for and also I can change the lighting
if I want I'm going to stick with aqua
the question I propose to you today is
is it a good thing or a bad thing that
we have not yet seen aliens because it's
for sure got to be one of the other
right so the lack of space sailings
becomes a bit of a problem once you know
how big the universe is and you start
doing a little bit of math if there's a
hundred million stars in our galaxy and
it seems like most of them have solar
systems it would be really weird if this
were the only solar system in the Galaxy
where there was some kind of
civilization building life one thing
that we know about us is that we take up
the available space and definitely
traveling between stars is very hard but
it does not seem to be impossible so if
that's the case then the entire galaxy
becomes available space and so it seems
It's good news that we haven't seen
aliens yet because if we did we would be
part of their available space but it is
important to recognize taking up all of
the available space is not just a human
thing if they could the ants would make
the whole earth ants trees would make
the whole earth trees bacteria would
make the whole earth back interior
camels would make the whole earth camels
that's not a human thing that's how
genes work so given that one all life
that we know of takes up all of its
available space and two we are not yet
part of someone else's available space
we have I think three options number one
we can definitely say with absolute
certainty that it is possible for a
thing like humans to happen in the
Galaxy because it's happened I'm sitting
in a pod at an airport so that's
possible however the universe is 13.7
billion years old and while life on
Earth has existed for about 28 of that
time which is a loss civilizational life
has existed for a vanishingly small
amount of time just a couple hundred
thousand years on the outside life on
Earth is not a blip but we are a blip in
terms of time so it is possible I do not
love this that while it does happen that
civilizations occur in the universe they
do not last very long we would conquer
the Galaxy if we had the time but we
simply do not we do not have the time
because things like this just don't last
this is talked about a lot in the sort
of communities where this stuff is
discussed there's even a term for it
that uh there's a great filter so the
great filter is just the thing that
prevents civilizations from existing for
long periods of time whatever it is it
could be AI it could be global warming
or nuclear weapons or social media maybe
Tick Tock is what does it like we don't
know now the second option is also a bit
of a lonely one that it's not that this
doesn't last a long time like maybe we
will last a long long time but it just
doesn't happen a lot and maybe it only
happens one time per Galaxy or less than
one time per Galaxy and the Milky Way
just got luck and in that case we are
both alone and extraordinarily special
but there is a third option that I I do
not hear people talking about very much
and to me it would be very good news
maybe this property of life that it
takes up the space available to it is
something that you can get Beyond maybe
we are already seeing a species on this
planet do that to start to pump the
brakes a little bit maybe that species
is us the first species ever that's
starting to think about not just taking
up the available space is it possible
that sufficiently advanced species with
sufficiently Advanced philosophies and
societies start to think more about
quality than quantity maybe there are a
lot of civilizations in the Milky Way
but maybe they don't take up a lot of
space maybe they're just not very loud
maybe they found a way to put a break on
their instincts and maybe we right now
are in the very beginnings of a similar
shift and in that case maybe someday we
will solve the Fermi Paradox by becoming
its solution and that would be pretty
cool and since I have uh six seconds
left in the timer John I'll see you on
Tuesday